[Music]
hi I'm Shane Harris with the algebra
cartridge extension system it's
officially Azalea season azaleas are
blooming and garden centers are full of
the plants trees ready for you to go
purchase them so what do you do with
these a is once you've mostly bought
them or you brought some home for the
new landscape today we're going to show
you how to plant those azaleas
when it comes to site selection on your
new zone you need to take a lot of time
to look where you're going to want to
put this particular plant does it need
to be near the house does it need to be
more of a natural area you want to give
it room to grow azaleas prefer filtered
Sun and afternoon shade in other words
they would prefer morning Sun maybe more
shade in the afternoon they will
tolerate Sun but they can get very hot
in the summer time also looking for an
area that's going to be well-drained
azaleas prefer well-drained soil but
cannot have any winter feet so an area
that provides filtered Sun may be under
pine trees just a few hardwoods maybe an
open area that gives a plenty of Sun in
the morning and afternoon shade when
it's hot this summer is gonna be ideal
as it should be grouped together based
on color or variety and spaced properly
around three to four feet apart
depending on their maturity size now
let's put the Azalea in the ground the
planting hole should be no deeper than
the depth of the container it came in
but at least twice is wide to allow the
proper root development one common
mistake is playing the azalea's too deep
in the ground adjust the depth of the
planting hole by adding more salt
underneath the root ball or under the
pot to get the correct height and depth
remove the Isaiah from the container and
massage and loosen up the roots along
the root ball this allowed those fibrous
roots to grow out properly in keeping
you from being pot bound while in the
ground a common horticultural saying
with azaleas is plant them high and then
ever die you want to be sure that the
root ball was about one inch above the
native soil level there's again if
they're planted too deep they will not
survive before adding the native soil
back into the planting hole and around
the Azalea it's a good idea to add a
little bit organic matter into the
native soil to have the best of both
worlds common Sol amendments would
include compost or fine pine bark or
they're store-bought soil amendment
almost finished let's add the native
soil and organic matter mixture back
around the Azalea gently pushing it on
east side and pressing downward so that
root ball is covered and all air pockets
are removed be sure not to bury the
plant above the top of the root ball
gently spread it out and firming the
soil with your hands now add a layer of
mulch around the plan choices could be
pine straw or even pine bark this is
very critical for the first year of the
Azalea as it will lose moisture since
its roots are not fully established this
is very critical the first year to
maintain that moisture in order to can
survive the hot summers the last step is
to give the Azalea drink of water you
will want to water the Azalea at least
once a week depending on the amount of
rainfall and how hot the summers may be
again spring planted azaleas will need
at least one year for those roots to get
well-established so again be sure to
water them throughout the year
azaleas are one of our prized Suns and
landscape plants because they last so
many years for more information on
azaleas and other home and garden
information visit us online at Asus dot
edu
or contact your local County Extension
Office